all right guys bang-bang super excited
to have Brooke on thank you so much for
doing this
yeah it's my pleasure thanks Anthony
found me for sure so let start with your
background before you decided to go out
on your own start cut capital what would
you do
so before I cap I spent 10 years I guess
you might say in the institutional
healthy world so I started my career
working here in Portland Oregon for a
family office consultants and yeah it's
a consultant that helps wealthy families
with their investments overall and build
a portfolio and generational wealth and
all the things you would think of but
specifically I worked in the private
markets team so our team helped these
families to invest in private funds and
that was effectively anything that was a
liquid not a hedge funds we're investing
in buyouts growth equity venture credit
real estate energy timber you know a
whole host of private strategies are
pretty broad world and did that for a
while and then actually moved out to the
East Coast for a few years first and
philadelphia with a firm called hamilton
lane which is now public company but
it's a massive private equity advisory
asset management firm based in
philadelphia and a similar model in the
advisory side they sent their clients
are more like big pension sovereign
wealth funds they have a very large
asset base because of that and they also
have a large discretionary business as
they manage fund to funds vehicles Coe
investment vehicles where they're
investing and directing companies along
sides for the managers as well as
secondary vehicles and in particular I
focused on secondaries there so we
managed a fund that would buyout limited
partners in you know different types of
credit funds we would help GPUs to
restructure their funds give an
additional runway help you know captive
venture and grab equity funds has been
out become independent and this was when
your dog frankly really taking affect in
terms a lot of financial service firms
you know basically having to get rid of
their their venture arms are critically
arm so you were involved in some things
on that side of things and you know
basically anything where you're buying
an existing portfolio of credit assets
you know from a managed by a third party
and you know did that for for a couple
years and then have a good four
to join a firm called Greenspring
associates which you know is now over a
ten billion dollar adventure platform
and you know they're models it's all a
venture capital fund of funds
secondaries and directs so they have a
number of different vehicles but you
know generally speaking spent my time
investing in venture funds and that was
funds like you know benchmark and Excel
and Bessemer and foundry and folks like
that and then a lot of emerging managers
folks like you know pair adventurers or
Pioneer Square Ventures up in Seattle so
really kind of the full gamut as well as
internationally on the secondary side
you know we were buying when a
partnership interest as I mentioned
earlier as well as direct second areas
of buying stock from founders early
employees management whoever it might be
but you're buying common stock from from
folks like that and then also just doing
very traditional group stage direct
venture so it was kind of you know
Series B and later we were you know
leading rounds you know very very
involved post investments so you're much
more of a you know true venture strategy
versico investment strategy like you
might assume given the fund of funds
model so you know did that for a few
years and potato helped to build up
their second rape and says well and you
know last year I was there spear and
their efforts in the blockchain space
and we can we can go more into that if
you'd like but you know as you might
imagine that's what what led to starting
cut capital yeah and so I want to talk a
lot about like the process you use right
you sat in the seat multiple times in
multiple firms so you kind of seen how
many people do this but one of the
things when you're sitting in that kind
of institutional LP seat is there's
people who have trusted you with their
capital and you know relying on you to
deploy capital but you're really doing
the work of sourcing vetting and
ultimately deciding or recommending hey
this fawned over another fund and so
they walk me through like what does that
due diligence process look like and then
we can get into some of the intricacies
as to you know where people kind of
stumble and where people thrive but what
is the process of due diligence look
like when evaluating fund managers yeah
so you know it's a very qualitative
process
you know unlike maybe I don't know maybe
hedge fund investing which is maybe much
more quantitative but it's a very
relationship driven business overall you
know if you just think about the world
of venture capital because these are
people who can be partnering with for 10
to 15 years so just you know getting to
know people you know making sure these
are people that you're going to you know
want to work with over a very long
period of time is kind of important
first step and just getting to know
these folks you know from a quantitative
perspective before kind of getting some
more of the qualitative assessments your
there is some work you can do and in
particular that comes down to analyzing
the track record and your cutting in a
lot of different ways so looking at okay
you know every deal they've done you're
looking at my partner looking at by
geography looking at by sector you look
at it by stage kind of all the different
ways that you could cut the data and yes
see what trends you can find from that
so you know maybe you see that there's
one partner who's really driving all the
returns maybe there's one geography that
they're really horrible at and they
clearly just need to stop investing in
or you know whatever that data tells you
and look at okay well how does that
relate to their strategy going forward
you know is that partner who has really
driven historical returns retiring or
whatever it might be or maybe they're
taking a bigger role and that's a great
thing and you're trying to draw
conclusions from that and then using
that to assess how their strategies
going forwards and you know hopefully
you know that it's kind of supports
their their continued strategy or you
know maybe that just leads to certain
questions around like attribution for
example I'm like oh look look at this
partner who's not there anymore and
somehow they are attributed all the bad
deals like that's that's kind of a
little little questionable Sophia tells
you a lot from that perspective but you
know generally speaking it is much more
qualitative right so you need to dig in
understand this strategy what's their
approach you know what's their process
to doing investments how are they
sourcing deals how are they working with
companies to you know as a board member
and you know helping to you know provide
value post investments and here's Chile
speaking like who is who are the most
sought after VCS by founders you know
who's seen the best deal flow who do you
know founders really want to work
and you know kind of taught founders
that you would want to have have access
to and you know how do they
differentiate themselves in the market
why are found are going to choose them
versus anybody else you know a lot of a
lot of that stuff which is you know you
just learn through conversation you know
is very important and then there's also
in the operational side right so what
does the firm look like what does the
team look like you know what does the
organization look like you know are you
comfortable with them you're their
ability to to run a firm and run a
business and build a team and bring on
talent and you know all of that is is
very important including you know
back-office and a lot of kind of the
more you know less sexy but important
operational things I guess one other key
thing is portfolio construction so you
know generally speaking you know I
certainly have a preference for example
I'd say most lp's do for you know
slightly more concentrated portfolios
versus like a broad spray-and-pray
approach and you know how many deals are
you going to be doing you know how do
you think about reserves for example and
you see you see that as a big issue with
a lot of first-time funds where they
don't realize they need to keep water
reserves to continue back in these
companies and end up with you know very
small ownership and you know they want
how they go to keep investing in their
best deals you know what kind of
ownership are they targeting just kind
of how are they planning on a lucky in
the portfolio in different ways like
that and it and it seems like it's this
weird balance between when you first go
in to do the due diligence you're really
kind of a detective right you're trying
to understand what's good what's not but
then once you say hey this is somebody
want to invest in at times you almost up
to become a Salesman now right now
you've got to convince them to actually
take your capital and so how does the
kind of experience that balance between
you you want to be able to do the
diligence that you want and sometimes
that requires questions uncomfortable
conversations you know kind of asking
for introductions to people that that
you can go do reference calls with like
all of the things that generally take
work and time and effort but then at
some point you want Toronto hey we're
gonna be a really easy LP right and you
should take our money it's like any kind
bounce that yes I think it really comes
down to the relationship that you build
with these folks and not just being oh
we have this elk he who gets our
quarterly poured and you know they come
to our annual meeting but we don't
really know them but really building
like a true person relationship with the
GPS that you're investing in and I know
that helps in a ton of ways just in
terms of you know they're being open to
you asking tough questions and you know
kind of the ability to increase act
increase allocation to you know top
funds in the future and stuff like that
but sorry can you repeat the question
again just like how do you how do you
basically balance between you know being
overly kind of investigative on the due
diligence process but then also at the
at the back end being able to you know
convince them to take your money over
maybe another lp's yeah so I mean I
think GPS generally understand you need
to go through your diligence like you
know just because you're having
conversation with about about the fund
that does not mean you're going to
invest in the fund it's just kind of the
process to diligence and you know
honestly sometimes you you do that you
you go through your diligence you end up
with a negative assessment and the GPS
are not pleased with it and I think that
kind of you know tells you you know
tells you something when that happens
but yeah I mean really really comes down
to to the relationship and you know if
if if you build strong relationship for
these folks they're much more likely to
be be hopeful for you to want to make
introductions for you you know to help
you with direct investments for example
and you know just kind of you know help
you out in different ways and you know
also about that when I mentioned about
being you know being a passive LP like
you know people want LPS we're going to
provide value to them as well so like
you know providing feedback seeing on an
LP advisory boards you know helping them
with all key introductions you even
providing them with zeal flow when you
see and stuff like that and finding
different ways to provide value as an LP
and I think you know if if you build
that relationship if you're providing
value as an LP you know like the idea of
convincing them to take your money
becomes a lot easier because you're
not just any other passive LP but you're
like a real partner for them and you
know there's someone that you they
really value having as an LP they want
to have his nel P and then you know that
the kind of sales process well yeah that
is always a part of it for you know
really hard to access funds you know it
becomes becomes a lot easier because you
know they can really see that it's
important to you and that you'd be a
great partner for them and you know I've
definitely been on both sides of that
you know in my prior experience I've you
know been at places where you know we we
lost access to really good funds because
you know we didn't properly build those
relationships and we were not you know
an ideal LP in certain situations and
then you know I've also been on the
other side of that you know like a green
spring for example where they focus very
strong those partnerships and you know
I've seen how that can really you know
you really provide value as an LP and
you know kind of increasing your
allocations with really hard to access
funds over time yeah it's awesome
and I guess what are like the major
points where you see fund managers
failed the due diligence process like is
there one or two things that you're like
these are just the most common mistakes
that people make so you got a couple
things I mean one you know there you
have to have a certain level of
confidence that they can be successful
in what they're doing based on you know
past history right so for a lot of
first-time funds and often it's not it's
not you know they're not at fault for
this it's just kind of inherent and you
know the in the process you know they
don't have the proper investment
experience or track record or the
ability to say hey I've done this in the
past I can continue doing this and
here's here's the proof of that right so
that's that's often an issue you know
I'd say another thing is just no
differentiation right I mean there's and
there's literally over a thousand
early-stage venture funds out there and
I mean if you're an LP you just have
your choice of so so many funds you know
you really have to figure out how are
you differentiating yourselves why
should I be paying attention to this
fund versus the that wasn't other funds
that are coming and talking to me you
know why do you stand out why are you
gonna get better deal flow and you know
you really have to be able to like tell
that story and make that very clear in a
an initial conversation so that when
people come away for that like oh this
is really interesting I think this
really stands out and you know kind of
just that like standing out from the
crowd given how busy LPS are how many
funds they're seeing it was really
important just in terms of you know
getting kind of second conversation and
progressing that conversation forward
obviously from a track record
perspective you know that there are
definitely funds that have done well
without frankly having an amazing track
record but yeah I'd say for you know for
the most sophisticated lp's you know
having that good track record you know
and you know being able to dig into them
and say hey you've been very successful
in doing that obviously is a is a key
thing yeah and they're certain you know
certain things that specific LPS look
for maybe it's like they don't they
don't like having single GPS or you know
other kind of specific criteria like
that where maybe it's just a small fund
and they don't they don't want to be a
you know above a certain percent of the
fund which you know similarly managers
can't necessarily do things and do
things about but you know there are
certain kind of criteria like that that
tailpiece look for is what look for as
well which can kind of be a negative
signal yeah make sense and then I guess
what have you seen maybe the best fund
managers right so kind of the top 1%
what do they do that separates them in
the eyes Association wall piece from
even the ones who are really really good
so like that the you know kind of 5 best
in the world from everyone else what
separates them i aside from just having
the brand having the reputation you know
kind of the the typical stuff you expect
I'd say one big piece of it is just
building like a lasting repeatable
institution so you know there are plenty
of good investors out there and a lot of
a lot of groups who like ok I'm gonna do
this for a couple funds and I'm gonna
retire or whatever it might be but I
think LPS are looking for and you know
the top funds are you end up being these
you know long lasting institutions that
can weather generational transition and
really really building out you know for
the long term so firms like I mean you
know once I mentioned earlier like
benchmark and accel investment they'd
all been around for for a long time
they've gone through generational
transition they've continued to be a
sought-after partner for all keys and
you know that's that's not an easy
process you've also seen firms that have
you know I guess I don't I don't name
certain names but how to have not done
well with that where you know they have
these amazing brands and then that brand
is really declined you know whether it's
maybe bad performance or they haven't
been able to you know continue to build
out the team continue to build out new
talent and you know how people want to
want to come there so but I think that's
kind of a underrated but very important
piece of it and so you at some point
decided hey I'm gonna leave and and go
kind of full on into blockchain and also
start your own organization so maybe
talk us through like what was the
accelerant for wanting to do that and
its really deciding - yeah so for some
background I guess and how that came to
be sigh my I've been tracking the space
for a while prior to capital and I went
to school with a couple guys for early
in the space and we graduated before it
McQuinn existed but you know they were
doing some interesting stuff later on he
caught my attention they were you know
doing well and yeah you understood at
first I I didn't fully dig into it I
certainly dismissed it a little but then
I started exciting started Greenspring
mid-2014 which I start doing venture
full-time and you know that space
started becoming a little more relevant
for my day job so I remember catching up
with one of those folks and it was late
2014 and you know walking me through you
know how they use their platform and you
know just moving crypto around for
example I was just kind of blown away by
how easy it was and how it was how
smooth and seamless it was and I
remember singing no doubt to the full
team at the time it's like hey we should
be tracking this company this is really
interesting and I didn't get a single
response which was kind of a sign of the
times but yeah I was paying more and
more attention to that space as I was
being venture full-time but you know the
problem is it wasn't at all relevant for
my day job so that really changed in
2017 we started seeing a lot of these
dedicated watching venture funds emerge
yeah you had a couple have been around
for longer but we saw you know a much
much larger in terms of fun size and
number of managers and part of those
managers and so I went out and like I'm
gonna go go out gets in all these funds
build those relationships you know
build relationships within space are
broadly spend a lot more time in
education and so I went out there and
did that and you know that led to spirit
in Green Springs efforts in the space as
I alluded to earlier and you know green
spring you know it wasn't a you know
wasn't the key focus for them and you
know I got to the point where I wanted
it's not my full time and attention on
it and it really felt at Grace provide a
pretty broad purview into all things
venture between the fund of funds and
the direct investments and whatnot and
you know I I just really felt like you
know if you looked at we're all on the
innovation adventure returns had come
from for the prior 10 15 years areas
like software and e-commerce and
marketplaces and on-demand and stuff
like that
yeah I feel like a lot of that was you
know somewhat played out and
opportunities between more niche and you
know much more saturated competitive
market obviously which has also been
flushed with a lot of capital and so
looking at like okay we're you know
where is real innovation going to come
from over the next 10 to 15 years you
know where do I want to spend my time
where true venture to return is going to
come from and you know came the
conclusion that blockchain and crypto
was was that space you unfortunately
couldn't spend you know my full time
attention on the Green Springs so left
to just start a capital which you know
we can we can go more into it if you
want but as effectively taking Green
Springs model and applying to the
blockchain space so it's put your fund
of funds and direct investment firm
focused on watching BC and so help me
understand like what is the argument for
fund of funds versus going direct to
managers for investors so people that
you go talk to and say hey you should
work with us versus go to a direct
manager what's kind of that pitch look
like yes I guess to provide some some
background just on fund of funds in
general to give give context maybe I
mean you know the fund of funds IV has
been around I guess since the 90s so
it's it's a modest than around for for a
long time and you have really started as
you know more like actually call
traditional fund of funds so folks that
were you know giving you an access to a
lot of like buyout funds and kind of
general private equities like hey you
know you don't know this base very well
you know come give us your money woman
you can just make one commitment and get
broad exposure to the space you don't
have to worry about it and you know that
was that became a pretty
pretty popular model they've seen a lot
of you know kind of pre sizable
businesses built around over time but as
LPS have become more and more
sophisticated and you know do more and
more of this in-house and just your
product has been around for longer you
know that that expertise and
relationships and access are important
so areas like you know venture capital
or small buyouts for example or
international like you know if you're
sitting here in the US investing in
China and emerging frontier markets is
you know is often difficult so you know
you've really seen fund of funds thrive
in areas like that and you know so why
would you use a fund of funds in in
venture capital and watch NBC for
example so you know there's a couple
reasons and depends what kind of LP you
are you know for smaller LPS or you know
smaller teams it really just comes down
to you know bandwidth an efficiency
right so if you're you know if you're a
smaller investor does it really make
sense to write you know five or ten even
smaller checks probably is not a
feasible thing you know for further help
ease in general I think folks in a space
like this really value the diversified
model and saying hey I can make one
commitment get exposure to let's say ten
funds and you know especially knows face
like blockchain adventure yeah I think
having exposure different parts of the
market is very important so you know
different structures different views in
the market different geographies you
know different structures and you know
it's often you know difficult for people
to take the time okay I'm gonna spend
you know whatever you know seem that can
amount of time is required to you know
really dig into the space get to know
all those funds you know make those
assessments and you end up making you
know a handful commitments it's just
much more efficient to outsource that to
Sonja has the expertise has
relationships you has the inside
baseball on on the market and the funds
and you know the the ability to you know
really do a lot of referencing you know
not just the ones they ask you to we're
all gonna say good things but you know
have the network within the space to
really dig around and you'll get to the
bottom of what's going on so you know
there's a handful of different reasons
and yeah I think over time as as this
space emerge you know uh sorry you know
you'll see what you see in the
traditional venture space which is
access also becomes a key a key thing
right because you know if you're if
you're in you know an LP and you know a
Sequoia or a benchmark or Greylock or
whoever you know that's that's not
something that's really repeatable so
you know if you're a new LP coming into
space having access to these funds that
are you know impossible to access is
also you know a key differentiator and
being will provide that access to LPS is
you know obviously a highly valued
resource yeah Mick makes a make sense
and I guess how do you look at kind of
the blockchain fund landscape right
meaning that first of all are you
looking at just VC or you looking at
kind of the entire landscape even liquid
traded funds etc and then inside of the
blockchain fund space like how do you
think about that difference between
structures and strategies yeah so well I
guess when we look at the bottom VLANs
VC landscape were focused specifically
on what we focus out at a capital which
is only closed and venture funds that
are focused on blockchain so you know
excludes hedge funds excludes you know
Highbridge hybrid funds as they're
called and I could get more to that but
these are all closed and venture funds
and that universe I think we're track
we're currently tracking 66 or 67 funds
that meet that criteria globally so you
know I think it's a lot more than people
realize there are quite a number of
funds out there you know what that
landscape looks like though is it's
about 70 percent in u.s. so in terms of
location of those funds a certain
majority are in the US you know the
other 30 percent are generally speaking
split between Europe and Asia and the
the landscape overall I mean it's a it's
a landscape of emerging manager for a
most these funds haven't been around for
very long and the oldest funds have only
been around for maybe six years which
you know for a venture fund really
really isn't that long so you know you
just don't have you know kind of these
you know like you know legacy
institutions that have been in this
space for a long time everyone's
effectively an emerging manager which
you know also kind of - the fund of
funds point you know increases that
value proposition there since selection
risk is really high when you can't
at a 10-15 year track record and you
know overall you know if you look at the
you know total amounts that these funds
are either have raised or are trying to
raise if they're raising right now you
know that number is about 4.2 billion
which Christ sounds like a lot of money
but you know relative to the overall VC
landscape it's like nothing you know
it's a very very small amount on a
relative basis so you know there is a
fair amount of money you know being
raised by these venture funds but it's a
very very small piece of the of their
overall venture landscape so yeah and as
part of that like when you look into the
different structures or VC funds right
it sounds like most of the structures
all actually line up for the most part
on the manager side like do you see the
emergence now of proceed see kind of
Series A Series B growth stage you know
kind of the mirroring of what you see
outside of the blockchain landscape and
venture or is it still so early that
you're actually getting firms that are
kind of playing at all of the stack
mainly out of necessity because the
companies need that their capital their
backing yes I guess for a quick context
you for asking that directly you know
but most of the closed-end venture funds
are investing a majority majority in
equity I say most also do you know not
all but most also do some level of token
investing but it's a generally speaking
a smaller piece of what they do and on
the token side that tends to be you know
very early stage and need in nature
because while those are still private
you know inherently they're kind of more
like the equivalent of seed stage but on
the other side specifically you know you
definitely see the exact same exact same
things using the original venture world
where you have you know the same series
of rounds pre seed seed Series A Series
B or whatever it might be for a specific
company and in terms of the venture
funds focus you know it really started
where basically everyone was a seed fund
right because if you look a few years
back I mean that was where you were
investing but you know just inherently
as a investor in this space and you've
real
seen that of all dispatch in the past
two or three years were there's much
more of a bifurcation now and I'd say
it's largely driven by fun-sized so you
have you know a handful of funds that
are on the larger end of the spectrum
and yeah those are kind of acting you
know they'll still still do you know
some seed investing like you know most
larger venture funds would yeah they're
really mostly capital is going to more
like traditional series a rounds you
know maybe there's a series be mixed in
there whatever might be be kind of think
of those is like your traditional series
a investors you know I'd say the bigger
portion of the market and mostly smaller
funds are you know see pre seed
investors but you definitely are
starting to see that bifurcation and
especially as so the larger funds have
moved up market in terms of fun-sized
over the past couple years you know
there's been an interesting opportunity
for new funds to you know basically fill
down a cap at the preceding seed level
and establish them as you know kind of
next gen firms I guess you could say at
that part of the market and then how do
you think about kind of the blockchain
funds interacting with the traditional
venture funds right meaning that if
you've got most of the blockchain
focused funds being kind of seed and
proceeded maybe even up to series a
obviously those companies are going to
need large amounts of capital later in
the stage of development and so you're
gonna have to rely on non blockchain
focused funds at least right now to kind
of continue to fund those businesses and
so do you do anything in terms of
understanding kind of the relationships
between traditional venture funds and
the early-stage blockchain funds or just
how do you think about that kind of
interaction there yeah I wouldn't say
it's a key part of a part of our focus
Matilda's perspective in terms of like
specifically what are those
relationships I mean it often does come
up during villages just given you know
all the model groups that they're Co
investing within their existing
portfolios for example but I would say
that I mean it is something that we pay
attention to in general for a real
really series II and later because you
have you have plenty of funds that are
doing seed investing and series-a
investing but you know generally
speaking the funds in this space are
pretty small it's not like you have you
know any a
has three billion dollars or whatever it
is and they can continue to fund
companies forever you know they are
clearly reliant on outside investors to
continue meeting future rounds you know
Series B Series C Series D so you know
I'd say you know given there aren't a
ton of companies that are later stage in
this space it's still kind of TBD in
terms exactly how that plays out I do
think you know they will be reliant on
journalists firms there aren't any you
know sizeable or maybe at all but
sizeable later stage venture funds that
it came to this space so you know
looking at funding rounds for some of
the companies that have raised like
Series B rounds for example recently I
haven't seen the issue raising capital
but it is definitely something that is a
potential concern we're you know
watching closely going forward got it
and then i guess another piece of this
is you also mentioned that you guys may
do some direct investing maybe explain a
little bit about what uh what you guys
would do there yeah so I mean so there's
other conversation around kind of the
fund of funds model another I'd say
important development in the fund of
funds world is that you can't really
just be a fund of funds anymore so you
know the the roofs have been most
successful have effectively built
platforms around the fund of funds and
if you think about what the fundamental
model is you're an LP and a bunch of
underlying funds you have access to all
sorts of very unique non-public
information on The Annoying portfolios
you know you have access to you know
board members or these companies you
just have very unique access to you know
in terms of relationships information
and you know if you're if you're
thinking about how can we utilize that
for the benefit of our LPS you clearly
you know the key answer to that is doing
direct investing and in particular for
us you know so we're not competing with
early-stage managers we don't do real
estate investing you know that's you
know that's much harder and we leave
that to our partners but you know what
we look to do is track their portfolio
companies and then you know try
effectively try to invest in their best
companies once they're really series B
and later and
you know we only do equities we're not
making you talking about token
investments but that could be anywhere
from doing you know a series be round
with a few million revenue on the early
side all the way through buying free IPO
secondaries and and everything in
between and you know also to the other
conversation around your the
relationships you build with these funds
you know we're not like we don't ask for
cohen doesn't write for example write we
everything we do is just build off of
the relationships we have with these GPS
and their information we have and you
know having them like want to help us on
deals and you're just having that kind
of be a regular part of the dialogue
right so i think that's a much better
approach than trying to structure where
they're like forced to give you co
investment and you know we're also not
co-investing per se you were kind of
coming in i guess technically after our
early stage managers would but yes
that's you know that's part of our focus
as well and you know we'll also find
other ways to you know create value
based on your relationships information
we have whether that's finding LP
secondaries you know that could
potentially be buying like GP stakes and
they're lying funds you know and just
looking for different ways that we can
you know use our position to our
advantage and for our LPS for sure and
then talking a little bit about your
interactions with founders I just and
the Direct Investing side that make up
some but also in the due diligence side
right of kind of diligence and the
managers themselves I'm kind of what
does that relationship look like and
kind of how do you normally go about
those conversations yeah it's a good
question so it is definitely important
part diligence and you know typically as
part of that you will talk to your
portfolio company CEOs so you know
you'll typically they'll give you a
reference list and it'll have you know
some number of names on it so yeah those
are good people to talk to
obviously they're you're gonna assume
they're any positive but you know it's
important to talk to those folks and get
that perspective you it's also important
to talk to people who aren't on that
list and you know to your earlier
comments around like you know being an
easy LP you don't want to just call all
their CEOs
like clearly disrupt business from that
perspective but you know it is important
that you talked to folks and figure out
who would be good to talk to who you
know he's not on that list or you know
maybe it's a you know instead of just
talking to the three CEOs who are their
best portfolio companies also talking to
ones who have been you have not done as
well and seeing how they serve as a
partner through that process of things
not going well right that's that's
obviously very important as well so you
know in terms of what you talk to them
about
I mean it's typically you know where do
the relationship come from you know how
did you get to know that person how did
they get interested in the company you
know why did you choose to work for them
or try to try it why do you choose to
work with them you know and choose them
as a partner was it because they just
gave you the highest price or you know
was it because you really valued them as
a partner he was in a pre-existing
relationship and you maybe you went with
them even though they they weren't the
best price you know what how they then
like to to work with you know post
investment
what's the cadence of communication look
like how are they as a board member or
whatever you know whatever that might be
you know just generally and how are they
viewed by founders in the space and just
kind of really digging into that
relationship and figuring out you know
why did they choose to work with them
how did they get access to the deal what
they didn't like to work with post
investment and kind of what's their
reputation amongst founders yeah it's
really interesting and then I guess
before we finished up I want to talk
about your LPS right and kind of the
conversations you're having on that end
so you go out you talk to people they
give you money and then you go make
these investments we're talking about
like what is that environment then like
as you talk to investors you know kind
of let's talk me pre-pandemic and then
post the start of the pandemic what's
change what are you kind of hearing and
what does it look like yeah so I mean
pre-pandemic I'd say trend wise things
were good in terms of LPS being
increasingly interested in this space
and you know generally just being much
more educated going into conversation so
you know if you compare it to a couple
years ago like the low level education
generally speaking that we have to do in
a meeting is much less than it was two
years ago and it's much more about you
know
what's our focus you know etc rather
than what's bla Chang what script though
so that that's been a really good
development and I think for a lot of
groups it's just been a very long
education process especially on the
institutional side you know and they
they have to get up to speed then they
have to convince their you know their
team and then their board and whatnot to
actually allocate capitals that's a long
process and yeah it's been good to see
institutions kind of get you know go
through that process and kind of closer
to allocating capital you know broadly
speaking you know definitely the when
the pandemic hit you know let's say back
in March
you saw a lot of folks basically just go
on hold like okay we you know the
markets down 20% over the past couple of
weeks you know we need to kind of just
put the brakes on here and see what's
happening you know for large
institutions where they were looking at
the space but maybe it wasn't like a
true priority it was just kind of
something that they were looking at but
you know not not a like a key focus they
definitely reverted a bit back to kind
of key priorities and you know kind of
their existing portfolio and kind of
managing the current environment you
know over the past I guess what four
months now you've definitely seen things
go a bit back more more to normal in
terms of LP conversations obviously
having the public markets recover is as
helpful you know the fact that it's not
necessarily tied to our underlying
economy you know is a separate
conversation but in terms of their
portfolio values having them recovers is
obviously helpful and you know it's a
also given you know some of the tail
winds over the past four months that
have been created in this space you know
just kind of increasing focus around
crypto as a potential macro hedge a lot
of you know certain folks who have come
out like Paul Tudor Jones for example
who has come out you know saying he's
allocating to you know to Bitcoin or
Bitcoin related investments you know
things like that have been very helpful
and just generally you know a lot of the
technology technological you know
tailwinds that you know you're seeing as
well and you know that's been good for
you know for certain corporate companies
and I think also just has broad
additional attention to the space and
kind of made people say hey I need to be
you know looking at this base to have if
I haven't been already so yeah that's
helped to offset some of the I guess
some of the you know folks who were kind
of on hold for enduring you know
probably pandemic and you know generally
speaking we're definitely seeing things
recover from that perspective got it and
I guess as part of all of this what's
been your biggest learning rate as she
kind of went out sort of Hut capital and
and it kind of gone through the process
that you've gone through what's been the
biggest learning that you've had or
maybe the biggest surprise uh yeah the
biggest learning has definitely been
fundraising so yeah I was not I mean
you'd be clear I was not responsible for
fundraising and my my prior you know
prior roles you know I was very focused
on investing so you know going out and
raising a first time fund as someone who
has not fundraise before has been a huge
learning experience in terms of you know
like what that process looks like a
building relationships and you know how
long that takes you know who you should
be talking to you know how you go about
fundraising just you know like who you
should be what are the different like
what are different avenues to try to
raise capital and find you know folks
that you should be talking to it's like
just the the idea of how you fundraise
has been like probably massive learning
and there's definitely been you know
mistakes I've made for that process that
I have one like okay maybe I wasn't
doing this the right way and I need to
kind of refocus on maybe this part of
the market for example from fundraising
perspective definitely just at our
strategy you know since since we got
started but yeah I think people
underestimate you know like the the
challenge of raising raising a
first-time fun and yeah it's uh just
definitely been a big learning it always
is what do you think all this is going
right in terms of kind of blockchain
venture does this grow into something
that remains kind of a subset of venture
does it kind of get as big as
maybe the way people look at FinTech or
consumer social or something like that
in the venture world where do you think
it's going yes like I'd say partly
that's depends on your view of the space
I mean III my mic rotation is that it's
something significantly bigger than
FinTech and eventually kind of ends up
eating FinTech you know given my very
polish review on on the space in general
I mean if you look at today you know you
you largely have these dedicated funds
who are investing in this space and it's
it's developed very differently than
what you've seen in different areas when
you think about you know it parts the
market like AI or you know I don't know
market places and like different your
other waves of recent technology you've
largely have the dedicated funds come in
and you know continue to get a lot of
the a lot of the gains and returns and
you know continue to do very well with
these different ways of technology and
then you know there's certainly some
dedicated funds that have been in there
but you haven't seen like you won't you
see in this space where you have this
huge number of dedicated funds who are
really you know the experts in the space
there where most of the top founders are
going to for for capital and you know
really kind of being like you know where
you raise venture money from in this
space so you know with with that in mind
I do think that is going to continue for
the foreseeable future
I've actually been honestly surprised by
that you haven't seen traditional
venture funds come into this space more
aggressively just I guess given my view
a bit although the same time you know if
I if I look back at my it myself like
three years ago you know it is a big
hurdle to kind of say hey I'm going to
allocate capital into this space for the
first time and something I don't fully
understand so I do think that's going to
take take time but yeah I think we'll
continue to see you know a large number
of these dedicated funds you the like
the the way that these funds invest also
is very different than in the
traditional world we have to worry about
things like tokens and you know like are
you going to stake your tokens and a lot
like a lot of the kind of crypto
specific infrastructure that a lot of
these journalist funds are definite
just not set up to handle you know the
expertise is very different and you know
if you're not spending your full time in
this space it's really really really
hard to really keep up with what's going
on they can't really access
relationships to you know to be a
successful investor so there's only
gonna be exceptions but you think you'll
continue to see the generalist fun try
the dedicated funds thrive and you know
be these sought-after partners in the
space you know eventually I mean surely
you will see the generalist funds spend
more time in this space become more
active and yeah I think that'll be good
for the market overall because it means
you know more capital will come in yeah
I don't think that's you know tomorrow
but eventually that will definitely
happen and you know I think that'll be
good for you no good for startups in
terms of how that plays out over time I
think you know if you live a long term
you'll have you know a lot of dedicated
funds in this base and I think you'll
have a lot of general response we're
also investing in the space much more
than they are today
why do you think the dedicated funds
given unique nature of this base will
continue to thrive and be a key piece of
the market yeah I love that before I
wrap up bias everyone the same two
questions the first beam what is the
most important book that you've ever
read hmm that's that's a good a good
question yeah I'm I'm not much of a
reader I'm much more of a of a music
person so I spend yeah I spend much more
time listening to it's an easy idea
reading but my most important book I've
I've ever read
mm-hmm honestly isolated not sure I
can't say that there's one that's you
know particularly influenced me you know
more you know I'd like it a profound way
or you know more than others in that
sense there's plenty that I've enjoyed
but you know generally speaking I'm much
more you know much more interesting to
music as a way to spend my time never
had anyone say that but that is an
awesome answer the next question is a
little bit more fun which is aliens
believer or non-believer I mean
absolutely believer I think just if you
think about how massive the universe is
the fact that we exist here it's just
it's incomprehensible to me that there
couldn't also be life somewhere else
that's evolved so I mean I I have to
think that there is life somewhere out
there in the universe and probably quite
a bit of it you know if you think about
the massive scope of the universe and
how you know you could have Lily
thousands of civilizations and not never
have one ever ever make contact with the
other so yeah I think there has to be
life besides us out there tend to think
that you're probably right well so we'll
see but I I tend to think so
to finish up you can ask me one question
what's the one question you have for me
so for your podcast series how much
preparation does it take to eat ready
for for a podcast so apologies even
asked this before but curious how much
preparation goes into it so I try to do
as little as possible actually and it's
this weird thing I've talked to other
people who have similar types of podcast
and in the beginning I would like to all
this research and show up and like I
basically in my head already have like
oh this is what we're gonna talk about
and what happens is it just becomes kind
of robotic and it's kind of like okay
I'm gonna ask this question I pretty
much already know the answer so I'm
asking the question then I'll ask the
next question and like it's just I don't
know it was less rewarding for me
because I kinda had already done all the
work and learned everything before the
episode started
so now you know I understand who the
guest is kind of their background
usually I'll have a couple of talking
points but then I just one have a
conversation and really ask the
questions that I'm curious about right
and kind of just naturally let that play
out and so it's become much more
rewarding experience for me to do less
preparation and and it seems like
there's a couple other people that are
kind of in the same same boat and so I
just remind myself that like you never
want to come unprepared at the same time
you don't want to show up and have like
every single question scripted out and
it's just you know like anyone could sit
down with the piece of paper and
basically fire off the questions and and
do the recording yeah I have to imagine
like the more of these you do you know
the more you're comfortable not having
everything mapped out as well so that's
interesting my friends sometimes will be
like hey man we're not recording a
podcast right now like stop asking me so
many questions I'm just trying to learn
just try to have fun right yeah awesome
we're on where can we send people to
find you on the internet and find out
more about a Hutt capital yeah so huh
capital you can find us at Capcom we've
also been doing a webinar series
featuring watch handy CDs which you can
find at help capital comm slash webinars
you can find me on twitter @ bh Paula
called I'm not super active on there as
well as hot capital which is that cut
cap on Twitter we've also done some some
writing on medium which is that you know
medium.com slash at cut capital and yeah
that's a good way to find us
awesome analysts thank you start taking
time to do this I think that uh you were
leading the way in terms of fund of
funds in the blockchain space so
hopefully you know more people will come
check our what you guys are doing and we
get some more capital into into the
space yeah thanks so much anything you
know a lot of fun and we she had me on
here so thank you